Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec ma plus jeune abonnée
la plus jeune des plus jeunes,
Bonjour
Andréa, c'est la plus jeune abonnée de ma chaîne
et c'est aussi la plus mignonne.
Et ouais !
Est ce que tu veux bien faire un tour de magie, pour moi pour la chaîne ?
Oui ?
En fait c'est juste pour remercier Fabien d'être resté plusieurs jours ici et à nous apprendre plein plein de choses.
On va lui faire un petit tour de magie pour le remercier.
C'est une recette spéciale viet, ok ? T'es prête ?
Je mets le feu attention
regarde
boum et on va étouffer un peu le feu.
On attend un petit  peu et à toi, mets le couvercle dessus.
Mets bien dessus et fais abracadabra
abracadabra
Pas de coupure de camera attention on fait ça.
Tiens tu souffles dessus !
Oh et qu'est ce qui se passe ?
Oh mais c'est trop mignonnn
Oh qu'est ce que c'est ?
C'est le repas de Fabien pour ce soir !
Et est ce qu'on essaie de le transformer ? 1, 2, 3 !
Quelques mois plus tard.
Oh mais c'est trop mignon, maintenant c'est un chiot.
Il est trop beau, t'es trop beau Lucky.
C'est la vidéo la plus putassière de la planète !
Regarde, "Bonjour !".
Un chiot, un chat et une petite fille.
Et c'est pas formidable ça ?
On fait des millions de vue avec ça Monsieur !
En plus il parle tout seul si je laisse la main en dessous là comme Jeff
Ahahahah
Est ce que moi aussi je peux te faire un tour ?
Tu sais dans la magie on peut donner l'illusion de faire des choses par exemple
si je mets la balle dans ma main, avec mon doigt en appuyant fort on peut croire qu'il y a 2 balles.
Mais tu sais, si je sépare, il y en a vraiment 2 après, t'as vu ?
J'ai juste envie de faire un mini tour de magie avec toi.
Est ce que tu peux mettre la main comme ça ? Celle ci je vais la mettre dans ma main à moi, celle-ci dans ta main.
Ferme bien le poing dessus. Tu fermes fort fort fort fort fort.
Tu mets comme ça, vas-y, tu ne bouges pas.
Regarde si je fais "clac", la mienne elle disparait tout de suite et toi, elle arrive dans ta main !
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé notre vidéo et nos tours de magie.
Si vous voulez faire plaisir à Andréa, n'hésitez pas, vous pouvez laisser un - POUCE EN L'AIR.
Si vous la trouvez mignonne vous pouvez également vous - ABONNER A LA CHAINE.
Et si vous trouvez que j'exploite des enfants vous pouvez le dire dans les commentaires.
Le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an. Rendez-vous demain à 11 h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !